comédien dramaturge metteur en scène et
directeur du théâtre du rond point
hilali esprit et humour avec talent et
il vous expliquera comment arrêter de
fumer quand on ne porte pas de pire que
louis 15 à la faveur de sa pièce théâtre
sans animaux qu'il sera présenté le 27
avril au prisme voici jean michel ribes
dans le kiosque
françois s'est marié avec la merde et
des bonnets des quand même bon c'est
maria costa toi ma mère voulait
absolument un enfant mais bien entendu
dans les règles donc mariage à temps
c'est vrai je peux pas le croire
on s'est mariés combat était pas venu
c'est une pièce écrite un peu ce test du
terme d'aéroports télé on monte dans une
pièce ça décolle et on n'arrête pas
forcément à la destination prévue
voilà certes une pièce pleine de rupture
de surprises et qui quand je les écris
voulais d'abord me déshabiller moi même
si je les écris je voulais que les
personnages me surprennent cetera et
finalement ils se prennent beaucoup de
gens aussi et j'ai l'impression que ça
fait rire beaucoup de gens parce que
c'est une pièce qui j'ai écrit de 15 ans
qui joue dans 14 pays qui n'en que
l'humeur scolaire etc femme un peu
dépassée passeur m'a torturé et luis
torturé pendant toute la soirée
oui bon ça va elle n'était pas sans
arrêt sur scène quand elle n'y était pas
été pire
pourquoi parce que je me disais la leyre
veut dire quelque chose qui fonctionne
ça monte si vous lui finalement le monde
totalement à l'envers pour finalement
dire qu'à l'endroit il est pas terrible
j'ai créé un peu comme ça ça me vient je
ne suis pas quelqu'un qui écrit sur la
réalité ce jour aucun journal en me
disant tiens il ya un truc formidable
sur la pollution sur la guerre en irak
sur les fusées qui exploite un pas du
tout je sais pas faire ça donc c'est un
peu un phénomène métérologique oissel
fuentes comme un nuage ça se remplit de
choses du monde et puis tout d'un coup
ça pleut mais ça pleut un peu en les
transformant est en tout cas moi je me
dis pages donne des leçons
je mets du sens non ça vient comme ça
avec le seul but c'est d'abord que ce
soit le premier spectateur de mes
personnages et qui m'amuse qui me font
qu'il me fasse rire et qui m'émeut il se
trouve que ce jusqu'à présent un être
humain donc d'autres êtres humains
partagent mon amusement un petit brun
foncé finira par le plus tu débarrasser
moins cher thiès a logé la jeudi alors
qu'il est 2,3 fois
oui bravo bravo deux fois cet hiver sera
presque pas compte dans la nuit sa pile
on n'a même pas le temps de penser est
ce que ça veut dire c'est un peu comme
au pardon hein tu dis oh pardon ne t'as
pas l'impression de demandes est
vraiment important de réclamer leurs
solutions vodafone non c'est une petite
phrase qui t'échappe et pourtant le type
sur qui tu viennes renverse et à bien et
capte et étrangers en attendant dire ou
pas dans sa prise de sitôt
comprenant que c'est pas un goujat qu'il
ya que je savais ce domaine dans lequel
bp il est devient son tour un peu
répondra je vous en prie pas venu non
plus n'a pas saisi le savent
sinon l'idée de se courber devant toi
mains jointes en clients l'auteur est
tout envie de la prononcer et pourtant
il la vie et vous séparer sans insulter
ni guerre presque amis pouvant que 10
milliards de civilisation n'ont pas été
vaines
est ce qu'ils ont réussi à remplacer
chez l'homme le réflexe de l'égorgement
pas celui de la courtoisie et c'est pour
ça jean claude que j'aimerais
petits-enfants qu'il bravo sur moi juste
pour qu'elle ne pense pas que mon mari a
échappé à la civilisation
dark ans parce qu' énormément de gens
m'ont demandé l'arpentage depuis dix ans
le public m'a dit mais pourquoi vous
refaites pas théâtre au bout d'un moment
je me suis dit je vais répondre à cette
demande parce que ça me touchait et puis
parce que si les gens en avaient envie
après tout c'est qu'ils avaient bon goût
c'est un gros lobby papa je sais que ça
un gros stylo bille papa énorme tu veux
dire
il doit peser cinq à six cents kilos il
est en plastique
ah ouais ouais c'est un vrai oui yann un
stylo bille utah beaton vient de tomber
dans le salon les créateurs il ya
philippe magnan évidemment annie
grégorio qu'il s'appellera et sont venus
compléter la distribution qui n'était
pas celle de la création
caroline avoir et marcel philippot mais
l'homogénéité la même et ça fonctionne
aussi bien que la création
j'adore toute cette période qui va de
vinci à warhol
moi je suis pour qu'on le rende 12
égyptiens tout mais qu'ils avaient misée
mio chf
je sais pas si ses rangs bronchait pas
si c'est bon mais on sait plus mal au
cul oui j'ai pas voulu reprendre la mise
en scène que j'avais fait à l'époque
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que je
voulais quand même qu'ils ne se soient
revisitées dans la mise en scène ça m'a
intéressé de voir comment on pouvait la
présenter autrement et surtout le
théâtre de tristan bernard il ya il ya
eu huit mètres d'ouverture ici en avant
donc il fallait médecins dans un espace
tout assez différents et nager j'ai fait
mise en scène sous les ailes ces voix là
on rentre dans une ville et puis on se
balade on va chez g20 coiffeur dans un
théâtre dans un salon enfin terra mare
merci beaucoup appris bienvenue et
maintenant un nouveau sujet de la
rédaction deux façades identique ou
presque
l'une restaurer l'autre dégradé par le
temps contrairement à la façade est le
pavillon ouest du palais du roi de rome
de rambouillet a retrouvé ses couleurs
décrite avant 1830
les enfants ont pu admirer le travail de
restauration ou comparant les deux
façades du palais qui n'a pas toujours
eu cette allure le palais du roi de rome
a été racheté par monsieur rassier dans
les années 1830 et monsieur ratier a
décidé de couper le palais du roi de
rome en deux il a démantelé en fait la
partie centrale de manière à pouvoir
revendre les matériaux et il nous manque
le corps de logis les enfants ont visité
l'intérieur du pavillon où ils ont
observé des portraits meubles et objets
d'art restauré pour initier les jeunes à
la conservation du patrimoine
l'exposition leur a proposé de
construire les corniches en plâtre comme
lors de la phase de restauration le
bâtiment qui est juste à côté
eh ben il est fait comme ça sauf que là
on a reproduit pareil sauf qu'on n'a pas
tous fini mais sinon c'était comme ça
l'exposition de restauration est ouverte
du mercredi au dimanche et se déroule
jusqu'au 28 avril
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
votre leçon de chant de gorge tibétains
rod taylor plus aura sundy plus ce
johnny clarke sont à la batterie à
guyancourt le 28 mars le grandiloquent
moustache poésie club sera quant à lui
le 29 au prisme elle en cours tandis que
l'humoriste nouara naghouche présentera
nick la misère le 29 mars à la merise
attrape des notes que vous pouvez
retrouver sur internet aux adresses qui
s'affiché cette semaine sur le www.club
ce que pointe ski point fr vous pouvez
gagner du 26 mars au 1er avril 5 x 2
places pour le plateau jeune humoriste à
la ferme du mousseau avec notamment kyan
khojandi de brefs alors bon spectacle à
tous et à bientôt
et toi tu enlève tes doigts de tomber je
t'ai vu oui oui je t'ai vu toi là-bas